H through H3 one of their main co-hosts
the Creator Ethan Klein has been
suspended off YouTube for the uh for the
week I think he's probably gonna be back
on soon for saying this comment
um Ethan Klein for the record is Jewish
and I believe he's an Israeli Citizen
and this is what he said about Ben
Shapiro I was just gonna say if there's
another Holocaust and people start
walking up did you
do this I just say if they start
rounding up the Jews again I hope Ben
gets gassed first
[Laughter]
so wait Dove can you say that
amazing if
I think that listen he's trying he's
truck funny it's a joke
naturally we all
we are jokes but
I was like one of those guys that does
not allow people to have context when
he's out there criticizing them so you
know what I mean yeah that's a problem
so I think that he's accused people of
being serious in times where they were
joking and uh now it's biting him in the
ass let's say if he wasn't a person like
that is that okay to say if you're a
Jewish person well he said can you can
you make the joke can you make that joke
as a juice right you're Jewish
thing happens
so that's it abide by the rules I guess
on yeah he's not saying that he won't
also be in there yeah like he's just he
would he would give just One's Gonna Die
at least I'll get a little Joy watching
that guy I hate him at first yeah I
don't think it's that bad especially if
you're Jewish listen Jews don't really
throw Holocaust jokes at each other
though that's all I like to think are
you not as much you literally said
Sean
that was a holocaust and he was like
that was my Holocaust that's what you
said you were saying I was not saying
like yo let me throw you in the [ __ ]
uh he didn't mean the news
[Laughter]
now I wonder if if YouTube takes into
account that that that guy is the type
of Dude to try to cancel other people
based on their jokes and I think there
was just a lot of reporting I think I
think a lot of business I think the
people who reported him probably took
that into it he's clearly being
hyperbolic yeah it's a joke ultimately
yeah and we got to support jokes
obviously yeah but we can also support
jokes and then not support his behavior
yeah so this is what Ben Shapiro said he
said I don't believe Ethan Klein should
be suspended from YouTube for his awful
garbage but I'll shed no tears for a
person who is routinely engaged in
cancellation of others world's smallest
violence good response yeah
honestly I hope you're not first
I hope you're not perfect
you know what that response
which begs the question
the classic sketch it's just a classic
fit
it's going on first
um okay all right what are we thinking
though what do we think about that
that's it nothing else I mean people are
like sell it here's the weird thing
people are like celebrating even getting
taken down
when I get it if you're annoyed by
Ethan's content he does a lot of gotcha
[ __ ] he seems like stir beefs up for
interest I I don't think that like he's
necessarily like an expert in anything
per se outside of being hated by people
and it not seemingly affecting him so I
understand if that is your Genius if
that is yourself superpower it is a
superpower it's a lot of people can't
deal with that type of hate he saw you
not deal with it yeah not at all I'm
lashing out yeah I gotta lash out
immediately but at the same time if you
don't have a
a skill set for entertainment outside of
that that's what you're going to need to
lean into yeah like we have comedy we
can make jokes there are other people
who are actors there are other people
who you know they're artists they do
these types of things if your skill is
you can hate me and it's okay
and I can deal with it you can get a lot
of views but you're gonna continue to be
hated to do so right and we saw him too
like I saw him do with the whole like
Bobby and kalila thing yeah you know
what I mean yeah and I've seen that
happen a bunch before so I think there's
a lot of people celebrating this but be
careful what you celebrate like I would
never celebrate this because I don't
want a joke of mine to cause our page to
come down so I cannot celebrate this
regardless if I agree with them or
disagree with them on things I have to
say do not take this [ __ ] account
down the [ __ ] is joking he's
also Jewish yeah he's he can make those
yeah they should take that into account
100 yeah like because they would take
down a white person's page if they said
the n-word but they won't take down a
black person's face the same thing
should apply to the joke they should
absolutely put his [ __ ] page back up
you know what's funny it's probably
anti-semites that reported his Holocaust
jokes 100. why can't we make jokes
yeah that's true